FOR THOSE WHO LIVE UNDER A
CATLESS ROCK TODAY IS NATIONAL
CAT DAY WHICH APPARENTLY SOME ON
TWITTER REALIZED IT COMES
EARLIER AND EARLIER EVERY YEAR.
BUT THIS IS THIS WEEK.
I'VE BEEN PLANNING IT FOR WEEKS.
IN HONOR OF NATIONAL CAT DAY,
LET'S PLAY RICH CAT/POOR CAT.
THERE IS A-- YOU CAN ALL HAVE
CHEESEBURGERS.
I'M SORRY.
I HATE MYSELF.
THERE IS NOW A TUMBLR WHERE
PEOPLE POST RIDICULOUS PICTURES
OF CATS SURROUNDED BY MONEY
CALLED CASH CAT BECAUSE PEOPLE
HAVE WAY TOO MUCH FREE TIME AND
OUR ECONOMY IS FLUSH WITH MONEY.
SO I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU A
PICTURE AND YOU GUYS HAVE TO
TELL ME IF IT'S FROM CASH CATS
OR SOME OTHER ABSURD THEMED
CATALOG WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE
ANY MONEY.
SAY RICH CAT OR POOR CAT WHEN I
SHOW THE PICTURES.
THIS IS AN ADORABLE GUY.
RICH CAT OR POOR CAT.
>> FAMILY MONEY, RICH CAT.
>> THAT IS A RICH CAT.
CHECK THIS OUT, DAMN!
THAT IS THE M.I.A. OF CATS.
>> NO!
>> I'M SO GLAD I GUESSED RIGHT.
THAT CAT WOULD MURDER ME.
>> WHAT SEASON OF THE WIRE IS
THAT FROM?
>> THAT'S OMAR'S BEST FRIEND.
>> OH, YEAHITIOUS THIS BLACK AND
WHITE PAUL OF FLUFF?
>> POOR CAT.
>> THAT'S FROM CATS THAT LOOK
LIKE HITLER.
KITTLER.
>> KITTLER.
>> ALL RIGHT, HOW ABOUT THIS
NEXT GUY WITH ONE EYE?
RICH CAT/POOR CAT?
>> RICH.
>> YEAH, DON'T WORRY.
HE'S LODED.
LOOK AT THAT.
AND A GRENADE.
WHAT?
IS THAT ALL FOREIGN MONEY?
OH, MY GOD.
>> HOLD ON, WHAT CAMERA AM I
LOOKING INTO ONE RIGHT NOW.
JUST FILM ME, RIGHT THERE.
YOU'RE FORGIVEN BIN LADEN.
THERE, GO AHEAD.
>> GOOD GOD.
>> THAT CAD CATIS SO EVIL IT
SHOULD BE STROKING ANOTHER
LITTLE WHITE CAT.
>> IT'S LIKE THE JASON BOURNE OF
CATS.
THIS NEXT ONE, THIS HAIRLESS
CAT... RICH CAT/POOR CAT?
>> POOR CAT.
>> THAT IS A POOR CAT.
THAT'S FROM CATS THAT LOOK LIKE
PUTIN.
BAM!
THERE IT IS.
I MEAN, WITH THE TIE-- IF OUR
SHOW WAS ON IN RUSSIA I'D BE
JAILED FOR NINE YEARS FOR THAT.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS CATS THAT
LOOK LIKE MY CHEESECAKE FACTORY.
LAUGHTER )
>> I HAVE A QUESTION.
DOES THE CHEESECAKE FACTORY
MATCH THE APPLEBEE'S.